them a text editor for writing code
where you navigate around the screen
with a keyboard instead of a mouse it's
based on the original unix text editor
vi which came about in 1976 then vi
improved or vim followed it in 1991 with
a bunch of improvements but why in the
age of modern ides would you ever want
to use a keyboard-based text editor when
you write code all day every day your
fingers should be glued to the keyboard
at all times every time you touch the
mouse your productivity declines
learning to code with them is like
learning to play an instrument it'll be
painful at first but that pain will lead
to more precise and productive code
editing in the future them runs in the
terminal and it's installed on almost
every machine and at some point you'll
likely find yourself accidentally
dropped into them with no way to escape
if you find yourself there you can quit
them by typing colonqueue that will
close an unmodified file or if it has
been modified you can use cubebang to
throw away your changes or wq to write
the changes and then quit now that we're
out let's use them to open up a file
currently we're in normal mode but we
can toggle between different modes like
insert visual and command line depending
on what we're trying to do we can move
around the text with the arrow keys or
the letters h j k l if we find a
character we want to delete we can hit x
or double d to quickly delete an entire
line if that was a mistake hit u to undo
it now currently the document is kind of
hard to read so let's add line numbers
by running colon set number and now we
can navigate to any line with colon
number now if we want to change some
text we need to go into insert mode by
hitting i and that frees up the keyboard
for us to type into the document once
we're done modifying our code we can hit
the escape key to go back to normal mode
but now like any good developer we need
to copy and paste some code in here from
stack overflow we can paste from the
system clipboard by entering plus p into
vim and now that our software is
complete we can hit colon w to save it
then run the program directly from bim
with colon bang followed by the shell
command we want to run congratulations
you're no longer a soy dev but a true
software engineer this has been vim in
100 seconds but stay tuned because you
don't need to ditch vs code to get the
benefits of vim that's why i invited a
true expert and the instructor of the
vim for vs code course joe previt to
take us beyond 100 seconds of them
hello everyone i'm joe and i will be
your guide as we go beyond 100 seconds
to discuss why you should learn vim and
how you can leverage it inside your
favorite editor vs code first let's talk
about why you should learn vim vim is an
evergreen skill meaning you can learn it
once and the knowledge will last with
you for the rest of your career it
allows you to work faster and more
efficiently within your editor here's a
side-by-side comparison on the left we
have editing with vim on the right we
have editing without vim
as you can see bim lets you do more from
the keyboard meaning you get to spend
less time editing and more time coding
now let's talk about how to set up vim
with vs code once you're inside vs code
head over to the extension panel
and search vim
you should see the first extension
called vim and to make sure it's the
right version double check that it's vs
code vim.vim and it should have around 2
million installations
go ahead and install this extension the
next thing we're going to do is set up
key repeat
so head over to google and look up vs
code vim github you should see the first
link which is a github repository called
vs code vim vim
there you're going to scroll down
to the installation section
in here
you'll see instructions for how to
enable key repeating
this is a handy thing to add especially
when you're new to vim because it'll
allow you to hit the key and it will
repeat
as in if you were to hit
j to move down
find your operating system i'm on mac
and then run this in your terminal
and now for the changes to take effect
you're going to want to restart vs code
to verify that it worked go ahead and
create a new file and now you should see
that your cursor is a little bit wider
go ahead and hit i this will put us in
insert mode and then hit return a bunch
of times
then hit escape
and now try hitting and holding k and
see if your cursor moves up
if it moves like this
pretty smooth then you've enabled key
repeating if it gets stuck then you may
want to try restarting vs code again or
revisiting the installation instructions
great now that we have our editor set up
i'd like to teach you a few different
commands in vim so we'll review some of
the ones that jeff mentioned earlier in
the video and then we'll also learn a
few new ones so inside vs code go ahead
and create a new file and save it as
hello.md now what i want you to do is
hit i to enter insert mode and hit
returns we add a few lines for us to
work with and then hit escape great so
the first commands that we're going to
talk about are for navigation and they
will be h j k and l
so right now we're in command mode so if
we hit k we'll start moving up if we hit
j we'll move down
so remember we just learned k for moving
up i like to think of it as kicking a
soccer ball up i'm kicking upwards on my
editor and j for jumping down use
whatever mnemonic comes to mind to help
you remember those
the next we'll talk about are h and l so
i'm going to write hello world here
and you can do the same so
again the way that i did that was i for
insert mode start typing hello world and
then when you're done hit escape and
you'll be back in command mode so the
first one we'll talk about is h so if
you hit h you'll start moving to the
left
as in you're moving to the beginning of
the line
also the h in hello world
now once we're there if we want to go
back right we start hitting l and that
will move us towards the ellen world so
again figure out a mnemonic that's going
to help you remember those for me
i like to think of h as in i'm going
home to the left
and then l
you would think that would be
l for left but it's actually the
opposite of that so l for right great so
now we're feeling comfortable with
navigating in vim again we're in command
mode we're moving up and down with j and
k
and left and right with h and l the
other thing to to remember is if you
take a look pause for a second look at
your keyboard see where the keys are on
your keyboard you should see the h
to the left of j and k so that also
helps me remember and then l
is to the right of j and k so it'll take
some time but once you got those down
you'll be able to navigate seamlessly
throughout your editor using vim so the
other thing i want to point out is you
still have access to your mouse so you
can click to move around
so there's no need to worry about
getting stuck in vim i'm sure you've
heard horror stories people not being
able to exit them luckily using them
inside of vs code we're really just
using the them key bindings so we don't
have to worry we can close a file we can
navigate
no need to to fear being stuck in vim
now the next thing i want to point out
is some editing commands so we will talk
about i
capital i
a
and capital a for editing in a line so
we're going to go back to our hello
world and you'll see right now the
cursor is at the end of the line if i
hit shift i or capital i it'll move me
in insert mode at the beginning so i
could write a word like
i don't know
joe and then if i hit escape i'm back in
command mode where i can move around
so you'll notice
the one thing that i want to point out
to a tip is a lot of vim users remap
their caps lock key to escape so instead
of
caps lock being caps lock when i hit the
key it actually is escape and so it's a
lot more accessible it's closer it's
right next to my pinky rather than
having to reach to the corner of the
keyboard and hit escape so that's one
thing i'd encourage you to look into
remapping your caps lock key to escape
if you're serious about learning vim so
we just covered capital i we know that
lowercase i
is insert mode right so now what i want
to talk about is lowercase a the thing
that you got to pay attention to here is
the cursor
right now it's on top of the exclamation
point so if i hit i it'll move to the
left and now if i go back now if i hit a
it'll enter into insert mode but after
the cursor
so like this
so again uh if we have like a number two
here and we want to add to the beginning
and make it 22 we'll hit i that'll let
us enter at the beginning and now if we
want to add to the end like say i wanted
to add a
period 22 so 22 22 then i can use
lowercase a so those are very handy when
you're inserting letters or making
changes
in a line now the next one that i want
to talk about is capital a and so this
is like appending to the end of the line
so you'll enter insert mode at the end
of a line so here i am and i want to add
more exclamation points at the end of
hello world so if i hit shift a it will
move the cursor to the end and it will
enter into insert mode so now that i can
enter a few exclamation points now if we
go back to the beginning
we can do shift i now we're insert mode
at the beginning of the line so as you
can see
the i capital i a capital a are very
handy for editing in a line
great
we've talked about navigation we've
talked about editing and align
now the last two that i want to talk
about are x and r and these are handy
for
making changes while in command mode if
we go back up right here and so i want
to get to the beginning of the sentence
so i'm going to hit shift i hit escape
because i want to be in command mode so
you'll see that i have four j's right i
don't really need all of those so what
we're going to do is actually use x to
delete those so x is kind of like x out
of character so i'll hit it three times
one two three and now i have one j which
is correct
so as you can see we're able to make
edits without leaving command mode so we
just talked about x for exiting out
characters now let's talk about r
for replacing characters so i'm going to
go to the h here and i want this to be
capital so i'll hit r and then shift h
which is just a a capital h and now it
will replace it and again i haven't left
command mode here let's do this for 22
22. let's change this to
uh 52 22 so we'll hit r and then five
and so basically what it does is it
replaces the character
under the cursor with the new character
that you type in so we've talked about
navigation with hjkl we've talked about
editing in line with i capital i a and
capital a and now i've talked about
making changes while in command mode
with x and r i hope you enjoyed that
brief introduction to them inside vs
code if you'd like to learn more head
over to vimfovsco.com
and check out my course it's got 100
exercises to help you learn how to use
vim inside vs code and we teach you 22
different commands
use the coupon code fireship for five
dollars off thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one